[Musique]
depuis qu'on a découvertes dans tout ce
qui brille elle a prouvé sa capacité de
jeu amoureuse incandescente enquêtrice
de choc coach acaria très même
psychopathe de compète dans la flamme à
la confirmé les espoirs placés en elle
avec ce César il y a 12 ans déjà le tout
en réussissant l'exploit d'avoir à la
fois à l'image d'une star glamour et
celle d'une bonne copine avec qui on
ferait bien un karaoké endiablé Leïla
Bekhti est en aparté
bienvenue en aparté merci refermez bien
cette porte mais voilà maintenant vous
êtes là vous êtes coincés je vous garde
mais avec plaisir gardez moi on est un
peu on est tellement content de vous
avoir enfin dans cet espace
bienvenue je vous en prie prenez le
pouls de toute façon la porte est fermée
à triple tour vous n'avez pas la clé
donc vous allez voir tout le temps non
mais ça va il y a pas de souci moi je
reste mais c'est trop mignon
et ben écoutez je vous en prie prenez le
temps d'explorer
des bonbons pourquoi faire ça
allez hop la tentation évidemment vous
résistez pas donc en aucun cas résister
pourquoi dites-moi un truc Adèle
Exarchopoulos elle a fréquenté cet
appartement il y a quelques mois elle
dites-vous que vous êtes une boussole
c'est bien non dans un appartement qui
est pas fléchés remarqué c'est pas mal
on s'en sort bien mais aussi elle aussi
c'est elle aussi c'est l'une de mes
boussoles ouais c'est ça elle dit aussi
de vous que vous êtes intègre juste
exigeante avec vous-même avec vos
proches allergiques à la posture elle
vous a bien croqué dessiner
en fait je crois que j'ai mon problème
avec la posture c'est qu'elle sait que
ça me fait peur en fait j'ai peur des
gens en posture parce que je les trouve
du coup pas très honnête et j'ai un peu
peur de la malhonnêteté
voilà donc
je m'assois je suis intimidé par tout ça
c'est vrai alors écoutez on va on va y
aller progressivement c'est vrai qu'on a
démarré par la tentation avec des
petites friandises pour essayer de vous
amadouer ouais mais vous m'avez bien à
ma douée c'est dégueulasse je vous
promets après on va être très souple et
très light demain soir Leila vous
remettrai un prix prestigieux vous serez
sur la scène des Césars
cette statue elle pèse son poids vous
vous êtes prête pour remettre ce prix ce
qu'on a le trac aussi quand on est
remettant
bien sûr on a le trac parce que on est
on moi j'ai envie de
moi l'idée de remettre un ses armes
[Musique]
me touche parce que je crois que ce qui
me bouleverse le plus dans la vie c'est
de d'être témoin du bonheur des autres
et là
et là j'aurais vous serez au premier
donc c'est mais bien sûr qu'on a le
train qu'on a envie de on a envie de
ouais moi j'ai envie de mettre en valeur
les nommés j'ai envie de j'ai envie
d'être
j'ai envie d'être sincère j'ai envie
d'être donc oui oui on a le mais c'est
un bon crack c'est c'est
de toute façon ouais moi j'aurais
toujours le trac quand c'est des quand
c'est pas un personnage là que je joue
c'est donc du coup je suis toujours un
peu un peu timide un peu mais bon c'est
voilà grand plaisir alors évidemment on
va revenir sur un épisode de fondateur
je pense chez vous il y a quelques
années mais avant ça l'année dernière
tiens vous aviez donné de la voix ou
presque un petit playback je sais que
vous affectionnez ça après la soirée
l'an dernier vous nous avez offert une
démonstration sur les réseaux hautes en
couleur on regarde on écoute
[Musique]
avec le bruit des portes et tout
évidemment
[Musique]
mais vous chantez pas du tout là
pas du tout mais pas du tout mais ça
vous c'est le principe
[Musique]
il faut savoir
garder sa place c'est à dire j'ai pas la
voix de Mariah Carey
mais j'ai les gestes la gestuelle
l'émotion effectivement le visage qui se
transforme il y a aucunement ma voix et
heureusement pour autant si on vous
propose le biopic de Mariah Carey vous
signez ou pas évidemment
mais il y a eu ce César cette cette
histoire très forte César du meilleur
espoir féminin pour tout ce qui brille
si je vous montre une petite image je
suis sûr que vous allez avoir les poils
qui se dressent un peu comme nous quand
on l'a vécu
César du mur espoir féminin et ma petite
sœur Leïla Betty
[Applaudissements]
je vais essayer de faire une vanne parce
que j'ai peur du coup j'essaie de faire
une balade
tellement j'arrive pas à les voir je
voudrais pas marcher voilà
vos yeux m'ont rendu plein et je suis je
suis tellement fier de vous avoir
rencontré je vais un peu dire n'importe
quoi parce que je suis trop ému
remerciez ma mère mon frère et ma soeur
d'avoir rendu ma vie plus belle plus
douce plus tôt et je vais finir par
remercier mon brin charmant qui m'a
avant toi il y avait rien mon cœur voilà
je t'aime merci
[Musique]
vous êtes hyper attachante cette émotion
elle va jusqu'à nous elle transpire bien
sûr
faut savoir qu'après les Césars il y a
toujours une fête au Phuket et en fait
en sortant des Césars donc j'avais
César et puis on allait au Phuket et
puis je dis au chauffeur monsieur je
peux vous demander quelque chose j'ose
pas depuis tout à l'heure mais est-ce
qu'on peut faire juste un détour par
chez moi il y a toutes mes amies
d'enfance qu'on regardait le la
cérémonie et je veux juste aller les
voir et en fait elles sont toutes
descendues elles étaient en pyjama
on dormait tout à la maison et on a crié
dans la rue et c'était merveilleux parce
que parce que le pas ne pas le partager
avec elle c'était donc c'était mon
groupe d'amis depuis que je suis toute
petite et après elles m'ont rejoint à la
fête ouais elle a fait et donc voilà ça
me rappelle aussi et puis les larmes de
Géraldine aussi elle était elle était
tellement Hervé aussi puis Pascal parce
qu'elle est belle avec qui je venais de
tourner mauvaise foi absolument il dit
ma petite sœur
dites-moi Leila là le César il est où
vous auriez pu le couper en morceaux je
me demande pour qu'il soit un peu chez
vos parents un peu chez votre frère non
il est chez mon frère en ce moment il
est il est en séjour chez votre frère
mais là-bas il me l'a toujours pas rendu
c'est pas grave il en mérite je pense
que vraiment ma famille elle en
mériterait on pourrait faire une
cérémonie que pour eux ils auraient le
César du Meilleur frère la meilleure
sœur la meilleure mère il y aurait donc
ils peuvent il peut le garder la famille
c'est votre armature ouais c'est plus
que mon armature c'est
c'est ma chance
j'ai beaucoup de chance d'être
ouais d'être né dans cette famille alors
il y a la famille de sang les il y a la
famille coeur la famille choisie celle
aussi avec une sorte d'évidence vous
avez parlé de Géraldine mais je parlais
je parlais d'eux aussi bien sûr c'est
une famille au sens large chez vous tout
ce qui brille New York j'irai où tu iras
on peut imaginer d'autres d'autres
aventures communes ah ouais ouais elle a
pas le choix de toute façon et puis moi
j'ai envie aussi de enfin ouais ouais
j'espère qu'on a alors on a rien
on n'a rien en projet concret mais
si si on va vous allez de vrai pour ah
oui oui alors il y a les César demain
soir mais il y a aussi votre actualité
au cinéma vous serez à l'affiche de je
verrai toujours vos visages le nouveau
fil de générique le 29 mars
jannerie ce film dans lequel vous
partagez la fiche d'ailleurs avec Adèle
exarcopoulos Dali ben salam you un film
qui parle de la justice
Jean-Pierre Darroussin je lis tous les
Denis
tiens un film sans artifice c'est
vraiment moi ce qui m'a frappé un film
très concret est-ce que avant de
regarder vous pouvez m'expliquer ce que
c'est que la justice restaurative bien
sûr donc là la justice restaurative
consiste à faire se rencontrer des des
victimes et des auteurs d'infraction qui
ne se connaissent pas évidemment dans un
cadre sécurisé c'est
[Musique]
c'est oui c'est abus de thérapeutique
c'est c'est des gens qui viennent dans
une démarche de de vouloir comprendre
et moi je ne connaissais absolument pas
la justice restaurative c'est vraiment
grâce au film de Jeanne que j'en ai
entendu parler je trouve ça évidemment
merveilleux je vous propose qu'on en
regarde quelques images et je vous pose
encore une autre question après
j'étais agressé dans le supermarché dans
lequel je travaillais à 5 ans je suis là
pour vous dire ce qui se passe pour les
victimes quand vous commettez ce genre
de choses j'ai 25 ans et j'ai braqué une
supérette j'ai passé toute ma vie dans
le monde des stupéfiants ça fait 25 ans
que je fais les allers-retours entre la
prison et l'extérieur je suis plus comme
avant ma vie est plus comme à vous
et si je résume avant elle était bien
quand vous parlez de peur vous voulez
dire quoi exactement quand vous attaquez
quelqu'un il n'y a pas qu'une victime il
y a d'autres victimes derrière il y a
des familles des couples des enfants
il y a beaucoup de travail j'imagine
pour ce film vous avez beaucoup de
textes Leila dans ce film lors de la
première réunion justement entre
victimes et agresseurs je crois que vos
premiers monologue il dure à peu près 9
minutes
c'est une sorte de défi quand même de
devoir parler comme ça en face avec
autour les autres acteurs vos
partenaires parce que c'est c'est déjà
c'était très important Jeanne elle était
il fallait absolument apprendre à la
virgule près et
donc voilà c'est chaque metteur en scène
travaille différemment c'était très
important pour elle et puis ça a été un
travail
[Musique]
il fallait absolument travailler avec ce
qu'on ressentait c'était assez
intimidant de en plus j'étais la
première à passer donc c'était assez
intimidant de de parler devant eux mais
comme le personnage de Nawel peut l'être
pour donc c'était il fallait absolument
que je puisse travailler
avec ce que j'étais en train de de vivre
aussi en tant que personne donc ça
intéressant quand tu peux tu peux les
donner à tes personnages donc voilà et
puis après j'ai vraiment je dormais pas
beaucoup je dormais deux à trois heures
pas nuit en début de film j'ai je
voulais être très fatigué j'étais très
mais j'ignorais même pas j'arrivais même
pas à dormir d'ailleurs alors comment on
sort d'un rôle comme celui-là parce que
effectivement c'est très intense il y a
ce huis clos quasiment permanent cette
tension aussi permanente
comment on sort d'un rôle comme celui là
bienvenue à la maison venez à la maison
et vraiment
il y a on se réchauffe là on se remplit
on se réchauffe et puis il y a trois
enfants qui vraiment alors vraiment le
le
rôle que tu viens d'interpréter c'est
pas qui sont ceux qui sont contrebalance
c'est que
vous voulez bien vous installer au
comptoir là il avait qui le bar
des surprises bref vous pouvez picorer
de toute façon et aussi du thé
je vous promets que si vous revenez et
vous reviendrez j'espère avec joie je
vous mets au défi nous faire comme ça un
petit truc vite fait facile parce que
vous avez franchement vous êtes un vrai
cordon bleu c'est vrai vous êtes vous
êtes la reine des fourneaux non ouais
ouais je suis la reine des fourneaux
c'est vrai non pas la reine mais on va
laisser ça à Jean Imbert et Cyril Lignac
mais
j'adore faire à manger vous êtes quelle
maman à table il faut finir son assiette
non je pense que j'ai pas ce
j'aime qui goûte tout ça c'est important
j'aime pas quand on dit j'aime pas alors
que on a pas goûté les trucs basiques
mais
mais après je suis pas celle qui va dire
oh tu aimes pas ce que ce qu'on a
préparé je vais te faire un petit
sandwich non il faut pas j'aime pas les
caprices j'aime pas la posture donc
j'aime pas les caprices évidemment c'est
cohérent vous faites toujours vos dîners
de Noël pour les amis qui ne passent pas
les fêtes de famille toujours je l'ai
fait cette année on était on était 38
mais vous mettez la pression c'est un
truc de c'est une industrie quand même
de devoir préparer pour autant de monde
non parce que j'ai de l'aide déjà
j'ai de l'aide et puis surtout enfin
voilà j'ai mes mes amis qui enfin on le
fait ensemble bien sûr bien sûr et mais
surtout ouais ce Noël des gens qui
fêtent pas Noël c'est c'est un truc que
enfin même pas que j'ai instauré c'est
pas vrai c'est mon frère et ma sœur qui
l'ont qui l'ont fait pendant des années
et puis et puis on a continué et
c'est je trouve ça joyeux il y a plein
de gens qui sont seuls pour Noël
là est-ce que vous voulez bien vous
installer dans le fauteuil gris mais
j'adore en fait je veux vous expliquer
un truc c'est moi qui vais pas partir
d'ici mais attendez je vous prends mon
je vous rejoins j'adore mange de trois
friandises et allons-y oh là là
la télécommande est à droite là
vous pouvez appuyer sur le bouton
j'adore j'adore ça
2006 sortie du film Sheitan de Kim
Chapiron produit par Vincent Cassel et
c'est votre première apparition au
cinéma
vous raconter un peu la jeunesse parce
qu'il y a eu un casting c'était mon
premier casting
mon tout premier casting
j'avais entendu Vincent Cassel sur canal
qui passait dans une émission et qui
avait fait un appel à casting donc je me
dis bon écoute je vais y aller et
j'étais un peu déstabilisé alors alors
que finalement ça a été ma chance c'est
que la directrice de casting m'a dit on
met de côté le
enfin qui met Gigi pardon m'ont dit on
met de côté le texte on va partir en
impro et il va te il va te draguer et tu
dois être timide
sauf que ne savaient pas que c'était mon
tout premier casting donc quand la
caméra s'allume
c'est la toute première fois de ma vie
que je suis
face à des gens devant qui je dois jouer
du coup je deviens tout rouge et je
viens toute rouge de timidité sauf
qu'ils se disent mais attends c'est la
timidité de la Seine donc voilà donc
quand je rentre chez moi je n'en parle à
personne
et surtout j'oublie mais vous sentez
quand même que vous touchez du doigt
quelque chose qui est peut-être fait
pour vous non parce que vous avez fait
un bac littéraire
j'ai fait j'ai fait du théâtre en option
lourde mais c'était un
vous savez le genre de rêve qui arrive
qu'aux autres donc c'est même pas
c'était même pas je le dis même pas
tristement j'étais pas j'étais pas assez
consciente que ça pouvait arriver pour
pour être triste que ça arrive pas en
fait
alors si vous voulez bien on va regarder
une autre image c'est vous qui allez
appuyer sur le bouton là
mais imagine 2 secondes ton père rentre
dans ta classe devant tout tes copains
délirant comme ce que tu as fait là tu
fais quoi tu réagis comment
c'est pas facile pour moi
est-ce que c'est facile pour nous est-ce
que tu trouves que c'est facile pour
nous
[Musique]
si tu avais pris ton lit car on n'en
serait pas là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
tu sais quoi c'est toi qui m'a oublié tu
me regardes toi est-ce que tu me
regardes non parce que je fais que
m'occuper de toi je fais que de regarder
mais tu me regardes moi regarde-moi
j'ai Brive et j'ai pris 15 kg en
deux ans
je me prends plus soin de moi je fais
plus rien je pense plus à moi
[Musique]
me dire
me dis plus jamais ça Damien je te le
jure me dis plus jamais ça
on est en 2021 c'est ce superbe film les
intrants
pour vous
ouais je suis une tranquille moi
je suis tranquille mais je
bizarrement j'ai plein d'endroits où je
me sens tranquille donc heureusement
mais c'est vrai que je suis une
intranquille de de
j'ai un besoin fondamental que tout
autour de moi ça se passe bien que que
c'est aussi très égoïste c'est pas non
plus que mais c'est vrai que
que ce film il a été
ça a été merveilleux de tourner ce film
j'ai adoré travailler avec avec Joachim
j'ai adoré travailler avec Damien
Gabriel aussi d'ailleurs c'était assez
intéressant on a vraiment travaillé
ensemble c'est génial d'avoir des
partenaires aussi généreux aussi
c'est difficile toujours de parler des
films que qu'on aime des gens qu'on aime
c'est dur je me rends compte là
alors si on parle d'une autre personne
que vous aimez il y a quelques mois
cette même place dans ce même fauteuil
tu as Rahim qui vous donne la réplique
dans la série The Eddie de Damian Chazel
nous disait je le cite il nous disait
être frustré de ne pas avoir assez joué
avec vous ajoutant même je voulais jouer
en face de cette actrice que j'admire
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas eu assez de temps
finalement c'est donc à refaire c'est à
refaire allez là c'est aussi un souhait
non je n'aime pas du tout cet acteur
j'aime pas du tout content
aussi de jouer quand on a sa vie
personnelle quand on partage la vie
oui et non parce que il a il a j'ai une
chance c'est que c'est un Rahim et que
c'est un très très grand acteur donc
quand je suis en face de lui c'est plus
impressionnant d'être face à un acteur
comme ça que ce soit mon mari en fait il
y a un espèce de j'ai énormément alors
je parlais d'admiration
j'ai énormément d'admiration pour lui il
le sait
et encore plus depuis que je le connais
parce que parce que il m'a il m'a
beaucoup appris tard sur plein de choses
notamment sur le cinéma sur j'avais
au début de ma
au début de fin quand j'ai commencé je
me souviens avoir été un dîner et puis
et puis on parlait d'un de Pia là je
crois et j'avais pas vu les films de
piala et j'ai quelqu'un à table et qui
m'a dit mais quoi mais tu as pas vu les
films
c'était hyper humiliant et
puis j'ai commencé à mentir quand
j'étais à dîner j'ai commencé à dire que
j'avais vu tel film que j'avais vu tel
film de kassavette tel film de et puis
j'ai rencontré Tahar
et puis et puis un jour je lui ai dit je
lui ai dit j'ai menti j'ai dit que
j'avais vu ce film parce que j'avais
trop peur de qu'on m'humilie encore une
fois et puis la fin un truc il a il a
il a pris son casque de scooter il m'a
donné le mien il m'a dit on va à la fac
et on a acheté plein plein DVD et il m'a
dit bah je les ai vu moi c'est film on
va aller je vais les revoir avec toi
parce que c'est ça les grands films on
les revoit plusieurs fois et puis tu vas
plus mentir en fait et c'est pas grave
et puis si tu es face à des cons qui tue
Milie parce que je leur dis bah c'est
pas grave au lieu de juste de me tendre
le film ou de me dire bah tiens
regarde-le s'ils ont pas l'intelligence
c'est la gentillesse de te et ça ça a
été merveilleux et mais c'est
j'espère que j'aurai la chance de de
tourner avec lui
c'est précieux tout ça vous voulez bien
qu'on regarde une autre image qui va
vous faire sourire
allez c'est vous qui allez
alors moi aussi j'ai fait un truc quand
j'étais petite que je regrette enfin que
je regrette c'est un bien grand mot
c'est bien de vous prêter au jeu
Alexandre allez-y on vous écoute j'étais
au collège j'étais très très amoureuse
de mon prof d'art plastique c'est la
tête de miroir
sous prétexte que j'étais mineur du coup
je l'ai assassinais
la tête de pierre
qui bouge pas
c'est la fin de l'histoire
évidemment évidemment la flamme série
Jonathan Cohen toujours dispo sur
mycanal et ce rôle culte vous êtes
Alexandra prétendants de sociopathe qui
est prête à tout pour repartir avec le
héros Marc bon évidemment vous vous êtes
régalé à peine imaginer j'ai détesté ce
tournage j'ai détesté on n'a pas pris il
vous dit à l'envie je crois il faut que
tu me saoules il faut que tu me saoules
c'était la consigne c'était vraiment le
cahier des charges c'était le cahier des
charges et c'était ouais c'était
vraiment le cahier des charges il m'a
dit sous le mois et donc là vous vous
êtes il y a rien de plus
je crois qu'il y a rien de plus saoulant
et de plus énervant que d'appeler
quelqu'un pour rien
c'est horrible donc là c'était à l'envie
c'était no limites
et no limites c'est ça c'est exactement
ça je crois que ce personnage il me
fait profondément du bien parce que je
n'ai aucune limite il y a un espèce de
truc c'est ma cour de récréation et en
même temps c'est là où Jonathan
ce serait pas le génie qu'il est s'il y
avait pas du travail derrière c'est que
c'est que c'est une cour de récréation
on va dire travailler bien travailler
Leila est-ce que vous voulez bien vous
déplacer maintenant parce que on a
évidemment pioché dans vos goûts dans
vos influences vous voulez bien vous
asseoir sur le petit tabouret à droite
de la platine enfin celle-ci voilà
celui-ci
on a pioché dans votre DVD tech dans
votre bibliothèque et au rayon Musique
on a
vous prenez brêle je crois ouais Brel
c'est il y a ces gens là
pourquoi Brel
pourquoi Brel Brel parce que ces gens là
c'est alors j'adore cet artiste mais ces
gens là en particulier
elle me
elle me il y a une phrase qui dit si
c'est pas sûr c'est quand même peut-être
je crois que c'est mon votre mantra
ouais ouais il y a tout peut être
possible
c'est génial
tellement qui boit tellement qu'il a bu
j'adore qui fait rien de ces 10 doigt
mais lui qui n'en peut plus
et qui se prend pour le roi
qui se saoule toutes les nuits avec du
mauvais
[Musique]
génial
qui est comme une saillie blanc comme un
ciel et tout mais c'est franchement
[Musique]
là on ne pense pas monsieur j'adore
cette chanson c'est fou
on brille
et puis il y a l'autre des carottes dans
les cheveux que jamais vu un peigne qui
est méchant comme une teigne même qui
donnerait sa chemise à des pauvres gens
une fille de la ville
d'une autre ville et que c'est pas fini
qui fait ces petites affaires avec son
petit chapeau
si vous voulez bien vous approcher du
canapé vous voyez les fleurs il y a deux
paquets juste devant vous donc c'est
l'émission la plus mignonne de mais non
mais d'ouvrir attendez d'ouvrir parce
que si on est à côté
alors on s'est lancé dans deux sens
voilà convergent mais différent
alors
ça c'est le petit coup de main pour vos
dîner de Noël
one pot Planet
pour j'adore
pour faire des recettes familiales écolo
un seul récipient vous auriez vous aurez
moins de messages one potpam c'est
génial ça c'est pour le petit coup de
main merci bon alors le deuxième
il est très très beau celui-ci
franchement c'est le nec plus ultra il
est vraiment un cadeau
la prochaine fois vous poussez la
chansonnette ou pas promis
promis promis promis bon voilà ça c'est
le petit cadeau les petits souvenirs
d'en aparté à la fois en cuisine et à la
fois dans le salon très entouré
évidemment vous pouvez repartir avec
bien sûr Leila oui oui oui mais moi je
vous ai dit je vais rester là ah bah oui
bah alors très bien vous voulez bien
vous voulez bien utiliser l'appareil
photo qu'on a mis à disposition dans la
dans la bibliothèque à gauche
mais c'est c'est super tout ce que vous
avez fait alors vous pouvez le tester
l'appareil parce que c'est un peu le
principe aussi c'est de nous laisser un
petit cliché de vous alors d'abord vous
allez appuyer sur le bouton orange vous
pouvez le laisser poser si vous voulez
pour qu'il y ait plus de distance pour
faire l'autoportrait vous appuyez sur le
petit bouton vous prenez la télécommande
la petite voilà vous faites trois quatre
pas en arrière trois pages je pense et
comme ça
c'est un autoportrait mais moins moins
gros plan waouh il a été refaire
en fait
horrible alors ne rappuyez pas mais
refaites trois pas en arrière
voilà prendre de dos alors c'est là je
crois que on l'a pas personne voilà il
faut peut-être se ah ouais peut-être un
peu de dos les acteurs ils sont pas
assez de dos ça fait du bien
par contre je prends je prends un petit
Twix pour la route une petite barre
chocolatée pour la route merci
infiniment merci pour votre générosité
merci vous étiez un soleil dans cet
appartement merci beaucoup je vous
embrasse Leila c'est le bonheur à vous
merci Salut Leila
parfois ils sont tous franchement
avec ses yeux mouillants elle dit
qu'elle partira elle dit qu'elle me
suivra alors pour un instant pour un
instant seulement alors moi je la crois
monsieur pour un instant pour un instant
seulement parce que chez ces gens-là
monsieur
on ne s'en va pas
[Musique]